en berry au centre géographique de la
france aux confins de la vallée noire le
pays de george sand la grande bête rôde
encore les soirs de morts-vivants dans
cette région morcelé en petite ferme
le sorcier fait toujours recette son
influence est réel heureuse ou
maléfiques
c'était sa recherche que nous sommes
partis et peut-être avons-nous parfois
frôler le diable son maître un village
comme tant d'autres mais depuis de
longues années la boulangerie est
ensorcelé le pas ne lève plus le
boulanger est tombé malade
bientôt la boutique sera à vendre comme
tous les après-midi la boulangère est
parti vendre son pain de ferme en ferme
dans le village
ceux qui savent murmure que c'est une
commerçante rival qui a jeté un sort sur
la boulangerie mais vous quand vous
croisez sept personnes quand elles
passent devant vous ne pas me dire
bonjour mais elle vous regarde tout à
leur nom n a été qu elle me regardait
alors vous qu'est ce que vous faisiez
mais je vous dis faisait signe de croix
je faisais toutes sortes de la
gendarmerie n'avait dit d'y faire le
signe de croix
ça suffisait ça oui à tout
elles sont en l'air comme l apr un lapin
à la rue alors quand vous lui faisiez le
riz la première fois de toute l'histoire
du panne alors j'en étais dans la moi et
mon mari quand elle nous a vus mais le
saut pendulaire metz fauté en l'air dans
la rue un tenait à rester comme une
folle ci avait rien eu
elle aurait pas fait ça donc moi je vous
le permettez à saute en l'air mais à
votre avis quelle attaque c'est votre
mari qui est malade
moi je rigole toujours attaquer mon mari
et et cette petite bête heures c'est
quoi cette petite bête c'est simplement
j'appelle la petite bête parce que nous
avons tellement cherché ça qu'on en
disait c'était la petite bête c'est
cette sorcellerie
alors ce ce coq noir il veut tout faire
bien vous diluez emmenez-moi remplace en
fait tout ce que je vous demande mais ce
coq noir c'est un éleveur de sorte que
vous a dit mérite de faire ça alors vous
avez
sadler de sorte qu'il nous a dit de
faire ça terre de prendre un coq noir te
le mettre dans votre grenier et puis et
puis de le porter après je vous dise un
tas de fumier de l'égorger a vendu
couper le cou le saigner non non vous
avez été tellement pour moi c'est
tellement des histoires de dans le temps
un puits du vieux temps et bien vous
savez que moi je trouve ça vraiment faut
avoir de père et mère pour faire des
choses comme ça j'ai des histoires quand
vous dites dans le temps mais finalement
vous ben oui quand un objet de refaire
pour se débarrasser de ces choses là et
j'ai vu même voyez un coussin si vous en
voulez là c'était le temps qu'ils
étaient prisonniers mais je conviens que
c'était en marne en seine et marne ou
quelque chose comme ça il sait qu'il se
faisait du mal entre voisins mais d'une
façon incroyable qui pourrait se faire
du mal et au point qu'après pour se
décharger de ce mal qui s'est obligé
d'arriver à noter des enfants c'est un
monte je désire vous êtes un coq
oui je délire non ou alors il s'agit du
délire de toute une collectivité car
cette femme exprime à voix haute ce que
tout son village chuchote il ya si
longtemps que la terre et les murs du
pays sont nourris de ses croyances
on y vit la sorcellerie au jour le jour
une sorcellerie dépouillé de beaucoup de
ses oripeaux fantastique du moyen âge
mais c'est bien la sorcellerie qui
explique encore parfois l'angoissent les
maladies la mort et c'est elle qui
habite déjà le paysage de ses enfants du
catéchisme
c'est quelqu'un qui fait alliance avec
le diable avec l'esprit du mal pour se
venger contre les hommes et faire le mal
les élites sont semblables créé tu vois
des difficultés dans la famille dans les
récoltes dans les animaux et même sur
l'individu se soucier c'est celui qui
fait mal parce que il est voué il est il
a donné il
vendu son âme au diable pour avoir
certains pauvres et il les exerce en vue
de faire le mal est ce qu'on connaissait
des sorciers qui n'habite pas loin d'ici
région faut-il te le dise tendant les
mains pas si j'en connais en tant que
prince et que j'ai eu affaire à eux je
peux pas le dire parce que je suis tenu
au secret professionnel et au secret
qu'est ce que le poulet doit dire tout
ce qu'ils voient non mais ben alors tu
vois je peux pas très bon de savoir
qu'est ce qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
joueur de 101 9 heures de sa voiture si
tu crois bien salée que quelqu'un de
famille en sort salit ou quelqu'un
d'audience harceler il va voir le
barreau de saint leu le voeu de sa qui
en faisant des prières au nom de dieu en
invoquant les bons saints la sainte
vierge va couper le mal barrés le seul
mâle café le sorcier ou alors il va
lever que veut dire le mot levé emporté
et soulevé emporté et si tu vois un
baroud sort il dira souvent eh bien mon
petit gars du bonhomme
la petite dame je prends l mal sur moi
vous pouvez partir tranquille et le
sorcier peut plus rien sur vous il a
levé le sort il a barré le sol toi
combien y at il des sorciers dans le
coin des dossiers en cours
ben c'est que mon billet je te connais
pas tous et puis je peux pas toujours
tel qu'il est à peu près dans le coin de
par contre tu veux dire par commune ou
comme les médecins par exemple du fait
que les médecins il y en a quatre
quatre ou cinq à la charge en as un tout
et bien sorcier
parce qu'il faut pas dû vous confondez
tout vous parlez de sorciers dans ceux
de barras est bien mais ton kana abe à
peu près autant que le médecin
[Musique]
la campagne elle-même justifie ses
croyances le soir la peur dessine
d'étranges apparitions de sud est comme
autrefois lorsque l'on se rendait à
l'achat ribaudes c'est à dire la veillée
non ça m'arrive vous y croyez au sort
ouais ouais ouais
nous verrons quand j'étais pas mal j'en
avais pas je t'aime bien
vous y croyez vous n'avez pas peur
moi j'ai doigts pourquoi ai-je les
doutes
vous l'avez vu j'ai perdu mais je n'ai
tellement écouter raconter que j'ai
confiance les chantiers vous doutez les
sorciers oui bien vous ne craignez pas
me forcer quelqu'un pour eux quand on
doute que les socios attendent autant
clegg
je me dis j'en sais pas jusqu'a demain
mais toutes les veilles de fêtes on
avait donc toutes les écuries des bêtes
on avait des petites bouteilles qu'on
empêchait de bélie sais tu combien
savent avec 17 et ont fermé toutes les
portes à main puis il ya ces scellés
l'inuit fin qui veille de fête où les
sorciers mais ce siècle son jeu le plus
dangereux
on ne peut pas affirmer c'est des choses
qu'on affirme sorbonne non ça se dit
qu'il est sorcier mais accusée que
calais de sorcier ça veut dire je me dis
je crois pas qu'il faut du mal à l'eau
non non on accuse quelqu'un est sorcier
sa 8e balle on dit les gens disent qu'il
est sorcier et on dit aussi mais un
clavier interview au monde
mais pourquoi parce que je trouvais
qu'il nous foute quelque chose il ya
rien enfin c'est ce qu'elle tourne donc
c'est zéro c'est nul 6-6 le pendule de
tourner par ben si elle ne tourne pas il
a tendance à voir quelque chose mais
elle doit donner enfin c'est et c'est
comme ça que vous avez découvert la
première fois que
sam est expliqué elle doit tourner dans
un sens généralement dans un sens dans
vos serrures immobilisé bombe en
immobilisant il automatiquement il ya
tout le temps des choses c'est à dire
c'est à dire faire quand vous dit
quelque chose c'est à dire un sort vous
avez découvert des preuves de de
l'ensorcellement de les tables ben oui
les veaux il avait quelque chose d'un
côté ou d'une autre qui était pas normal
que le vétérinaire ne dépiste les
médicaments font rien il connaît pas
j'ai près près de l'étape vous avez
découvert quelque chose
j'ai derrière l'écurie j'ai trouvé des
petites pierres d une fois quand c'est
écouter plus comme une plume des objets
inhabituels ou enfin les objets ou avec
la pendule qu'on arrive à trouver la
vieille montre du grand père est devenu
magique
depuis qu'elle sort de pendule grâce à
elle cette femme a pu découvrir ce
qu'elle appelle des charges maléfique
monsieur l'abbé au cours de toute votre
expérience toute votre ministère vous
avez vu des gens qui sont installés vous
voir parce qu'ils étaient pas ce qu'il
se disait envoûté est ce que vraiment
vous avez pu constater des signes des
preuves de cet envoûtement
c'est très difficile pour un prêtre de
s'exprimer sur un tel sujet c'est un
sujet tellement profond qui elle atteint
la personne dans son homme dans son
esprit dans sa conscience dans tout son
ensemble psychologique
il m'est arrivé de voir des personnes me
dire j'ai été envoûté dans telle ou
telle circonstance par quelqu'un qui
ment voulais et j'ai un clou du cercueil
d'enfoncer la dans le coeur et il faut
absolument lever le sort croyant
réellement que le clou du cercueil
s'enfoncer plus profondément dans leur
coeur dire qu'il n'y a pas en voûte mans
c'est très difficile de la part d'un
prêtre
car si lui-même affirme à cette personne
qu'il n'y a pas envoûtement qu'il n'y a
pas ça c'est qu'ils ne croient pas et si
le prêtre ne croit pas à la présence du
diable aux maléfices
comment pourra-t-il dire qu'il croit en
dieu vient trop souvent vous consulté
pour vous demander d'exorciser oui une
vingtaine de fois dans l'année donc pour
la connaître une vingtaine de fois dans
l'année
que faites vous là et bien quand dans le
diocèse
lorsqu'on est pris à monseigneur bagnard
joua l'archidiacre il me délègue pour
aller voir tel autre cas bien précis et
si c'est dans les paroisses ou que je
suis chargé
je vais même sur les lieux et jantes en
contact avec les familles qui se croit
victime de sortilèges de sorts ou
d'envoûtement
[Musique]
un crucifix un rameau d'olivier une
fiole d'eau bénite la sorcière bénéfique
et parfois à la lisière de la religion
ici on l'appelle pensée est venu là pour
penser un enfant des convulsions
c'est à dire pour le guérir des
convulsions comme d'autres femmes
pensent des brûlures des tartes ou des
verrues toujours selon la même technique
les impositions de demain et des prières
murmuré brière qui doivent rester
secrètes la penseuse implorent les bons
saints comme elle emprunte au
catholicisme tout son arsenal symbolique
un soir d'orage notre dernière visite
fut pour un ami dans les villages on dit
de lui qu'il éleveurs de saur est sans
doute le plus puissant de la région lui
répond simplement qu'il exerce le métier
de hunger est aussi qu'il connaît
beaucoup les hommes
si ça continue pour la conf et demi que
ça pareil là on prend un coup et bauchi
et quand on se trouve en face de
phénomène et c'est inexplicable enfin on
n'a pas envie de chercher à comprendre
une saveur un peu la barre social sa
chan est d'avis que saïda lui-même et
c'est un peu problème s'il peut pas le
dire
vous avez quand même ici vous les
personnels sont quelque chose
ce phénomène comme tous les domaines
quel effet la sonel
vous regrettez votre réputation de
l'homme c'est souvent trop sèchement
police ne passait pas que justin s'est
étonné ça vous a jamais créé de toasts
réputation de l'ovaire de surf on vous a
fait aussi
je fais gens sont méchants et dans tout
ça
le méchant que si on vous a fait cette
réputation c'est pas aussi que conduire
on dit familièrement que ce qui peut
faire du bien être aussi tous là de
ferdinand née de façon là ni de l'autre
je veux encore plus mal loti quand même
à ceux qui nous ont fait bien clément
fait du mal quand je peux je fais du
bien l'a conseillé de me faire fusiller
par la guerre quand je vois la lampe à
l'appareil mais l'ambassadrice
ok je vais prendre une maison et a
choisi d'initier véhicule a fini sa
région c'est bien on va faire payer
on va poursuivre il y est même si j'en
fais j'ai fait pas mal de contrat du
genre est encore fait du bien à
quelqu'un qui vous a fait du mal mieux
je le fus 10
je suis la plus folle que moi ce
lendemain orages les blés était couchée
en longues griffures dans les champs
autrefois ce matin-là on aimait à dire
que les sorciers le diable avait mené
grand sabah toute la nuit parmi les blés
[Musique]